The wound hasn't healed and
there's no tag.In
order to control the master who was resurrected by Ed's reincarnation, it's
necessary to have a tag implanted in his head.There's no
doubt that this guy is acting under Zantour's orders.Strictly speaking.  Even if it's a different technique from Ed's reincarnation, the
basic theory should be the same.If so, it should
n't be possible to forcefully overwrite the technique and make it obey this one.The
anger and wounds
hurt, so
don't worry.  I
just created a camping situation to
cool the wound
[music]
Listen to me in your eyes It's
only natural that you're angry.
If it's
me, I'll bring it back, but to do that, I
need your cooperation
[Music]
Now
pour the cherry blossoms directly from the mucous membrane underneath
[Music] Have you
overwritten reality?